keyboards Mouse's headsets Ram liquid
coolers cases mouse pads SSDs M twos
power supplies speakers and even gaming
chairs courser sells them all but
they're established just 25 years ago so
how did they grow from being a small
start-up to being an unforgettable name
in a gaming industry coming right up
[Music]
welcome to Harvey's hobbies I don't want
to bore you guys with a bunch of facts
and dates so here's just a quick
overview of their roots courser was
originally incorporated in California in
January of 1994 so just about 25 years
ago the company was founded as coarser
Microsystems by Andy Paul Don Lieberman
and John be clean coarser started off by
developing l2-cache modules or cash on a
stick Coast modules but soon after into
incorporated l2-cache
into their own CPUs with the launch of
the Pentium Pro family as a result there
is no more reason for coarser to linger
in this arena - they quickly shifted
focus onto the DRAM market mainly in a
server area in 2002 courser began
shipping dear modules which appeal to
computer enthusiasts who want to
overclock their RAM since then Corsair
has continued to produce memory module
for pcs and added other PC components
Carolina as well Corsair has sits at a
variety of high-end peripherals high
performance air water cooling solutions
and other enthusiast grade components as
well hopefully that quick history lesson
wasn't too boring so how to course your
go to the top of so many different
markets when there are so many
competitors there as well for example
coolermaster and thermal tech in the PC
case market and later NZXT
g.skill in the DRAM market and of course
their biggest competitors logitech and
razor in the peripheral market
especially considering that peripherals
are newer endeavour for Corsair
the key to their success in the
peripheral market is their marketing
team and the demographic that they
initially targeted according to Greg
ayahs who is the marketing director
sir Harker targeted PC gamers who had
pre-built pcs or the casual gamer who is
actually a make of most of the gaming
market anyways as a result while razer
was targeting enthusiast gamers by
advertising to them and sponsoring
eSports events Coursera was appealing to
that average guy who just wanted to play
better against her buddies and this was
perfect but it's not only what is marko
worth over a billion dollars but razer
wasn't really targeting this demographic
at this time razors slogan is literally
built by gamers for gamers this is
clearly targeted towards the enthusiast
gaming market now this isn't to say that
they are not successful because they're
one of the top sellers in the peripheral
market it said their revenue comes from
a different place one of the other key
metrics that coursers used to reach the
casual gamer was her social media
presence courser had a huge focus on
increasing impressions that activity
online and as a result they built a
social media team whose whole full-time
jobs was to engage the community on
various sites like Reddit Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
so this sub course initially stepped
into gaming peripheral market by
targeting casual gamers and growing and
large social media presence but that was
just the beginning and coercion wasn't
just going to ignore them Tuesday gaming
community either and by looking at Razer
and Steel series and their more gaming
oriented locals culture thought that
they should make their own gaming
oriented logo as well courser believed
that was important for them to rebrand
themselves to be more gamer II in order
to appeal to the enthused a teeming
market and as a result they came up with
a new logo which was to sorts costs
together but this was not received well
by their loyal fan base while the logo
wasn't bad by any means it just didn't
feel right and like a Coursera product
anymore and as a result there was a lot
of backlash and soon after course we
moved to a new logo that's very similar
to the original logo the sales this was
a iOpener for corsair they realized they
did not have to try to emulate other
companies and if they already had a
great fan base and just had to be
themselves after that initial small step
back courser started to work
building an enthusiast fanbase once
again while they also sponsor eSports
events and gamers their main focus was
definitely on influencers cars have
reached out to big tech youtubers around
the world and also attended packs and
Blizzcon for the very first time of
course you didn't have a huge marketing
budget so this was the perfect move for
them giving you three units two big
youtubers would you introduce your
products to millions and millions of
people along with their own social
communities furthermore in their own
social media communities there were
never sales driven they simply wanted to
be a positive community member and this
is essentially well won over the hearts
and minds of many gamers now that they
have become a big reputable company it's
time for them to launch prize oriented
towards enthusiasts gamers their first
product like this was of course the k70
rapid fire which is launched at PAX East
they also created a lot of enthusiasm
using their social media accounts which
got them a lot of great sales out the
gate they slowly perfected the strategy
and developed it into a strong launch
strategy their social media presence was
crucial in sparing their name and
building a large loyal fan base it is
one thing to launch one successful
product but it is completely different
to continuously launch successful parts
in different segments of peripherals and
according to courser the core reason to
their success in all of these different
regions is their hide focus on PC gaming
courser isn't trying to sell high
quality studio headphones or keyboards
for offices they simply want to make
great gaming products for the gaming
market and this laser-beam focus has
really proven successful for them there
are outstanding choice and materials and
awesome support have just helped them
solidified this position in the
peripheral market but what about other
markets other courser succeeds there as
well like the case power supply drm and
of course liquid cooling market well if
you guys didn't already know of course
it was actually the company that
invented the all-in-one liquid cooler
category and that's why they are so
dominant in the 120 240 280 and 360
millimeters liquid coolers NZXT is
starting to catch up
Stella quacking series but courser is
continuing to launch late liquid coolers
they seemed to have a great grasp on the
market moving on into the case market
hot of course or make a name for
themselves here as well
well actually up until just a couple of
years ago coarser wasn't nearly as
popular in this segment so what was a
sudden change that happened in the last
couple of years while courses are a huge
trend in our GPM tempered glass and
accentuated on this growth one of their
most iconic cases of all time nor does
is the coarser crystal 570 X which has
tempered glass on four sides and three
pre-installed RGB fans right at the
front this case was targeted at the
premium market with a price of over 150
dollars but with the recent obsession
over RGB and tempered glass this proved
very fruitful it was so successful that
they even locked the coursers slate
which is pretty much just a beefed-up
version of the coarser of 570 X but for
$400 other companies have done just this
as well for example NZXT is classic
minimalist s340
and thermal techs all tempered glass
cases are very iconic in the PC market
and have come to define these companies
as well in the case market at this point
we can see a trend with Coursera they're
very keen on what the market is looking
for and capitalized on just that
as for DRM courser started off by
producing DRM so it is no wonder that
they were successful in this segment as
well their implementation of RGB in a
variety of different RAM sticks has
really helped them appeal to almost
every demographic there is however while
they are successful here they're by no
means dominant in this beam these
killers definite their biggest
competitor and a GC code trying to Z RGB
and of course your vengeance RGB are
very big rivals of course Aaron g-scale
are very close to each other when one
company implements RGB to take advantage
of the market the other one does as well
and at the end as a coarser orange e
ckio have really come out victorious in
the DRM market but that isn't to say
that coarser is very popular in
um market and finally power supplies and
this is where the power of the courser
fan base really shines through coarser
isn't a pioneer in this market like in
the AI yo market or in the DRAM market
they haven't really made any iconic
power supplies or emphasize on any
trends either they simply make good
quality power supplies which are priced
the same as our competitors but what
separates them from their competitors is
your high oil fan base
this royal tea along with one key reason
has a lot coarser to sell law or power
supplies than their competitors so what
is this one key reason that they are
successful in the power supply
arena and this one key reason doesn't
just apply to a power supply market this
is action one third main reasons that
courts are as successful as a board and
this key reason is cohesiveness and that
brings me into my final point
cohesiveness courser sells everything
that a gamer will need when a person has
a courser keyboard it is highly likely
they will also buy a courser mouse mouse
pad and headset it is unlikely they will
switch brands for other peripherals and
when they are looking to build a new PC
it is easy protected by a new quarter of
case but of course your RAM courser
liquid cooling course or power supply
for surf and course sir everything when
a person has a good experience of the
Corsair prod is highly likely to go by
other coarser parts because of the
cohesiveness off all the quads which is
emphasized by the q software you don't
have to deal with the hassle of having
different software's for each of your
peripherals you can control it with just
one the q software furthermore when a
consumer has a positive experience of
one of course here as parts next time
one that they are buying a new pod
it slightly taper for coarser product
because they expect to have a positive
experience once again even if another
product gives them more features and
options and this is our coarser really
shines even though they're not the best
in any one category there are plenty of
headsets from SteelSeries and both which
cruise much better sound quality there
are plenty of nos from Rachel perform
better than m65 and other popular core
services and there are plenty of ramp
gifts are less expensive and coursers
RGB ones but that is all irrelevant
because even though they're not the best
in one category all of their plots are
of high quality and come with great
customer support as a result even though
they are not the master of any one
segment they're a jack-of-all-trades and
that made them wildly successful and I
would say this is the key to their
success and this is work time and time
again from many different companies in a
variety of segments for example Asus
with their motherboards GPUs cases
headsets keyboards Mouse's monitors and
laptops along with the powerful Republic
of gamers branding has built an audience
that want everything to be from Asus
another great example while not as
prevalent right now is sony sony blu-ray
players tvs sound systems consoles the
video cameras and laptops
people love to repeatedly buy things
from one company the first part they
bought that company proves to be very
pleasing and in the PC gaming market
horse's paws are the most cohesive parts
there are and this cohesiveness is a key
reason for purchase outstanding success
so here's exactly of course your couch
at top of a gaming market in just 25
years they were the pioneers to DRAM an
all-in-one coolers they approached a
peripheral market using a unique
strategy at the time they launched some
iconic products and built a strong base
of loyal fans to your social media and
most importantly the app should listen
to what their customers wanted and
actually made change based on that this
outstanding support along with the
cohesiveness of all their products have
allowed them to thrive in the PC market
and made them a go-to option for many
gamers and this is how they grew to be
the course that we all know and love
today so what company would you like me
to cover next make sure to comment that
down below also if you guys enjoy this
video and powers up well then make sure
to drop a like and consider subscribing
if Lexi or we do is just like this one
but till then I'm Hari
I'll see you guys on the next
you